Welcome
And
thank you everyone. We understand
this is the last session of the day.
And I really thank you for being
here. This
session is biz 208,
how to enhance your SAS application.
With Amazon Quick Suite.
We are going to talk all about
how to.
Get value as well as velocity
with Amazon Quick Suite
as well as ISV independent
software vendor SAS applications.
We will talk about what's not working,
what has changed, and
how you can innovate
with your application and Amazon Quick Suite.
With that, I'm Sonali,
Sonali Sahu.
I lead the global specialist solution
architect team focused on generative AI
in AWS and I'm honored
to take the stage
with Brandon Idelson.
Chief ecosystem Officer of
Zoom,
as well as Bibhuti Sinna,
Chief Product Officer for Savient.
Brandon. Well, it's
wonderful to be here at Zoom. We're
building a
platform that is the AI first platform
for work,
and as the chief ecosystem officer, I'm
all about how we build connections
across the tools that people use every day
to help create an amazing ecosystem
of systems working together.
So excited about the content in today's session.
Thank you, Brandon. Bibuti.
Thank you all. Thank you very much for being here. And
uh Bibutiana as chief product officer of
Savient. Our mission and motto
is to secure and govern every identity,
be it human,
non-human, and now of course AI agents
which everybody's raving and talking about.
So I'm really looking forward to talk about
what we are doing in this space, how the
overall identity security ecosystem is evolving,
and looking forward to this session today. Thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
With that, let's get started.
Quick quick agenda.
A quick introduction
about Amazon Quick Suite focused on
specific features
for your SAS application.
Then we will talk about two
different
SAS application integrations,
Zoom and Savient with Amazon QuickSuite.
Finally, next step and call to action.
With that, let's get started.
I will start out with something which
feels very real to me.
My everyday work
used to start with
opening up multiple different tabs
and tools before even I get
to my first
email of the day.
One tap for data,
another for insight,
another one to reach out to my teammates,
another one for decision, yet another one
to actually execute the action on
that decision.
Every single hop,
every single jump slowed me
down. It's a friction.
And this is not the story
of me alone.
I know this is the story of every
single user in modern day
era. Can we give
the time back to the employee
so that they can focus on the outcome and
decision? And not this busy day
work. For
that reason, we have Amazon
Quick Suite.
Amazon Quick Sweet.
It truly reimagines
how the modern day work happens.
First, it collects combines
all the data.
On top of the data, it offers
agenttic capability with custom as
well as chat agent.
If you have a need for automation, it
offers
quick automate as well as
quick flow
for orchestration work.
Additionally,
it offers deep research
capability with your research
agent.
It also offers the BI capability.
So you can think about Amazon
Quick Suite as a unified
agentic
workspace
for any
user.
And
how is it possible?
This is possible because
of our collaboration, Amazon Quick
Suite collaboration with our ISP
partners.
We are on this together.
We are going to deliver end to end
context,
research, insight,
everything in a unified platform,
wherever the work is happening.
We truly believe.
That
this can be delivered with an ecosystem
that no one can deliver in isolation.
And that is why when you combine
the agentic AI capability of
Amazon Quick Suite
along with the deep domain
segment or vertical expertise
of our partners, you get something
transformational.
You get the unified workplace
where the insight flows effortlessly
without any friction.
And this is not something
that is happening in future. This is
already happening.
So let me show you what are the
features offered by Quick
that your SAS application
can leverage to integrate
and enhance with this.
Two pillars we will talk about.
The first one is index data.
And the second one is the actions.
We will go one at a time and look into
the detail of those pillars.
Index data
One of the core foundation.
Of Amazon Quick Suite,
it says knowledge based and data
sources.
It can collect data from multiple
different data sources,
whether it is internal,
such as your wiki or product page
or internal communication channel,
or it can be external,
such as your
project task management on Asana.
Or you are talking about your meeting summary
from Zoom
or any other third party
application like Confluence, Jira.
So all those data can be
aggregated, combined as well as
indexed.
Quick not only
understands, but also maintains
the permissions and access
control set by the
applications. It solves
one of the persistent problems
that we have been talking about to
find the relevant information
from the data source. It truly democratize
the access
to your data
with enterprise grade security.
It's the high level overview of index
data. Let
me now show you
how your SAS application.
Can integrate with this index
data. I'll
walk through this high level flow.
On the very left hand side.
You are seeing Amazon Quick
Suite, as already discussed,
the knowledge base and data sources, one of
the core functional foundation
for Amazon Quick Suite,
that is there.
It supports both structured
as well as unstructured data.
It supports end to end enterprise
grade security,
security rested,
as well as security in transit.
And now
this index data can be accessed
from the
SAS application.
On the very right hand side,
you are talking about your SAS
application. That is your life data,
your customer data, your proprietary
business intelligence.
From your SAS
applications,
now you can call into this index
data. How that is possible?
Because of the middle layer,
that is the interoperability layer.
And why are we doing this?
We are doing this for our customers.
Now our customers can
access
their index data from both Amazon
Quick Suite
as well as the SAS
application of their choice.
They get benefits in two specific
areas.
One
is
clarity, and the second one is
speed and confidence in their workflow.
The first benefit clarity.
So customers have index data.
Your SAS application now can combine
this index data with the live data and
can give the end to end context
to your customer,
so they get the clarity
and the context.
The 2nd 1,
the speed and confidence in your workflow.
Customer has one index data
that is in Quick.
Now the same golden data
that they can access from the
application of their choice.
Not only the data we are talking about, your
application can combine the indexed
data, live data,
your tools, your applications,
and can give the enhanced.
Workplace for the customers.
That means they don't have to stitch
together anymore
any additional tools and
applications. Now
that we understand how this can be done.
I'm very happy
to share
our partners
who have already integrated
their applications
with our index,
our customers.
They can go to these ISV
partners applications and can
leverage the index data from
that application.
Now let's look into the 2nd pillar.
That is the actions.
And again,
I'll walk you through
the similar, a little variation
of the diagram.
Like how
your SAS application
can be integrated
with the actions on Quick
Sweet. On
the left hand side.
It is Amazon Quick Suite.
That is your AI teammate.
In addition to the data,
knowledge based and data sources, it also
offers actions. It has over 2290
actions
already supported
on Amazon Quake.
You can also orchestrate
this action
with quick automate and quick flow.
Additionally, Quick also
supports a managed MCP
model context protocol client.
With few configuration parameters
on MCP client,
now customers of Quake
can call into any MCP
server or actions of
their choice.
As mentioned before, QuickSuite already
supports the, uh, security
addressed as well as transit.
With the MCP client, it
additionally supports different types
of authentication.
We are talking about three-legged
authentication, 3 yellow or 2
yellow. So
that is the left hand side, Amazon Quick
Suite and its actions.
On the right hand side,
that is yours as application.
That is where
you will decide
to host
your MCP server that
can expose
both the tools as well as
agents.
Your tools can map back to your
operation, code operation,
create, update, delete, delete
uh type of operations.
Once you
have the MCP tools,
as well as agents on your
SAS application.
With the authorization of your
customers,
they can access those actions
from within Amazon Quick
Suite. How that is possible?
Because of the intermediate, the middle
layer that you are seeing in here.
That is the interoperability layer, which
offers
both built-in.
As well as MCP
Open Protocol standard. You can think
about the middle layer as a bridge that
speaks the common language to bring
in Amazon Quick Suite on the left
to the SAS application on the right-hand side.
So now you saw the end to end
integration,
how a SAS application
can be integrated with Amazon Quick Suite through
an actions.
And I'm happy to say that these
are some of our ISP partners
in third party applications.
Those are already integrated.
With Amazon Quick Suite.
Our customers
can directly go to Amazon Quick
Suite, and can see those
actions and can use those actions
as they need it.
Now that I have walked through all the features
of Amazon Quick Suite and how
your SAS application can use those
features and enhance your
application and what is the customer benefit would
look like,
now I'll take a pause
because I would request Brandon
to talk about how they have integrated
their Zoom application
with Amazon Quick Street.
So Brandon,
thank you so much.
Well, it is so exciting to be here
to talk to you about Zoom
and our journey and how we've integrated with QuickSuite.
But before we dive into all of that,
I'd love to maybe set some context
here. When we look out
in the world these days, and we talk to customers,
we hear that the world has become noisy
and fragmented.
Now this probably rings true to everyone in this room,
having walked the strip and the exhibit
hall. It's a little noisy here at the conference,
but this is going beyond conferences.
Workers are seeing more and more
applications in their
environments that they're being asked to use,
and AI is starting to get rolled out,
but it's becoming another tool, more
friction.
And folks are going,
how do we leverage this technology to
do better?
And it's a clear challenge, and the market
signals of this are extremely
clear. When we look at
the statistics,
most organizations have over
93 applications
deployed across their IT infrastructure.
Think about the context switching when you're going
between that many apps and onboarding
employees.
And so employees are looking for amazing
AI. Most
are looking for something that is purpose built,
that's gonna help them do their job better.
And
when you then talk to the IT buyer.
They are investing in AI because
they know how important it is.
So the market signals are
clear, this is the time, there is
the demand.
So it's really about how we action this
as ISPs to take advantage of this
moment. So
with all this, you might be asking,
why Zoom?
I know Zoom
because of the video conferencing.
How does this fit in?
Well, Zoom is actually a suite of
products. Video conferencing was our initial
flagship, but we've grown beyond that
to a whole suite of communication, collaboration,
business services, to help across
a full range of business use cases.
So we are helping people with their video conferencing,
but also helping them run their contact center,
whiteboarding,
collaborating in whatever format works
well for them.
But what you'll notice here,
across this entire
diagram of our suite of products,
is there are two things bookending it.
At the top is our AI platform,
with AI Companion, that serves as
connecting tissue across
all of these features within the platform.
But then on the other end, as you see on the bottom,
there is the ecosystem.
Because we realize that it is important to
connect across
so many different tools that individuals use.
It's part of the reason that Zoom has a chief ecosystem
officer, and that's the role that I enjoy filling.
Now, when I say an open
ecosystem,
I truly mean open at Zoom.
We don't think about just integrations, it's
really about how do we connect
to the tools that folks want, because
we don't want to replace the tools people
have. We want to integrate seamlessly,
so we're matching them and meeting
them in their flow of work.
And when we can build these experiences,
where you are able to connect
data with the context, with the workflow,
you create these magical moments
where AI actually turns into something
that isn't just supporting, it's fully
enabling someone with their day to day work.
Now, for us, AI has been a journey.
Just a few years ago,
we embarked on this by releasing our
AI Companion
1.0, that started off with meeting summaries.
But since then we have continued to evolve the
solution
and are moving towards an genic framework
with our
uh AI Companion 3.0.
And we're very excited about what it can
do, and what an agenic
framework allows and how it starts to
connect work.
Now, in order to do this and really
have something that's agentic,
we can't just work
within our product, we have to be able
to meet people where they are.
And so with 3.0, we're actually
expanding this platform
to work across someone's day to day.
You're seeing two examples here in the slide.
On the left, we have my notes, where
someone is, as you can see there,
in a Google Meet,
but they're able to take notes using
the Zoom platform,
so we're meeting them with the tool in the session
that they need.
On the flip side, on the right, you can see
someone that is using our AI companion
3.0 for web,
and they're querying it, but they're getting
value from integrations that they've
made with
with other
products that they're using, such as Google Drive and
Confluence.
So it's all about bringing the data
and the user into that amazing
workflow,
exactly where they want to be.
And so that's why
we wanna work with the tools that people use
and not work around them.
Because when you start to think about it.
When you connect the context to the work,
it creates this magic moment because,
because the AI then knows the context.
It's aware of what's happening and you start to
get to these moments where you can actually take a
conversation all the way to completion.
And so that's where we're designing and
working on fitting our solution in.
Now, it's been very exciting working with
Amazon, because we've been able to deliver
on this value.
And one of the great examples is the integration
that we already have and that is working
today with Amazon
and AI Companion.
Tell me if this example rings very true to
you. You're in a meeting.
Let's say,
talking about the latest sales numbers, or maybe it's
a project planning meeting.
There's that question that comes up where you need.
An answer to it,
and how often is it that that would become a
follow-up to go deep dive in the data.
But with the power of having these platforms together.
You can use AI that has the context
of the conversation about what was important
with the index data
that Amazon has gathered
across its indexes and merge that with
AI so you can get the answer in
that moment and it's no longer a follow up, it's
actually a completed action, and
you can move the business
forward and continue to move faster
at the growing pace that we have.
And that's what truly excites us.
But this is just the beginning of this journey.
And as we all know, AI
is evolving so quickly and
in opening so many cases.
So along with that,
Zoom is continuing to invest,
and one of the areas that we're investing in
is MCP.
As was mentioned earlier,
this is an exciting new protocol,
and we are really excited about it
because it allows us to extend the
number of tools and connections
that are available
in the Zoom platform.
And by connecting them, we're giving
access to the ISPs
that folks want to use in their day to
day work.
And MCP due to its scalable nature,
makes it very easy for us to onboard
additional
uh folks into the ecosystem,
and really unlock this connective tissue
across an enterprise's tech stack.
Now when I talk about MCP.
We're actually looking at it in two different
formats.
On one hand,
Zoom wants to be an MCP client to be
able to use those actions that
are available from other ISPs
so that they can access it within Zoom.
But really, if we want to meet users where they are,
it's also about Zoom providing an MCP
server
so that for other products and solutions,
they can access the tools that Zoom have and
meet the users in their context.
And I think that's what really excites
me when I talk about the work that we're
doing with QuickSuite.
Because when you think about this,
we're now talking about the ability of
two agents to be able to work
with one another,
to empower the user and meet the user
wherever they are.
To get the job that they want done,
we're removing friction and complexity.
The UI, the experience they want,
it's there, and they have access to
the data, the actions, and
everything to get the work done that they're trying
to do so that the technology fades
away and they can focus
on the work at hand.
So this is what's really exciting to me.
And this is an area that we're embarking in
right now.
And so with that,
I'd love to show you.
The work that we've been doing
with a very first preview out of
our labs
of that MCP server exposing
our whiteboard feature that could be accessed from
QuickSuite.
So if we go to the video here, you can see that
someone has been working in QuickS Suite,
talking about an OAth flow, and it's
describing how that works.
But words are one thing, you sometimes want a visual
to understand that.
So they can prompt within QuickSuite,
and as it thinks through it, it's able
to know that Zoom has a whiteboarding tool
that can take
that narrative and turn it into
a sequence diagram.
And so within a moment.
Zoom has already come back with a quick
link to pop someone instantly in a whiteboard
that they can look through that sequence that they just
saw described verbally,
and they can then go in and edit and modify
it. Think about this and
this use case across so many different
business processes.
And this is just the beginning of
what we're looking at.
So, I'm very excited seeing
what we're doing here.
And I know there's a lot more that we're going
to do.
When I look at our road map.
This whiteboard is just the beginning.
We're looking across
people's day to day work effort.
Whether that's helping them prepare for the meeting.
Providing insight within the meeting,
or taking those after actions,
providing these options up so that
Zoom and QuickSuite can work seamlessly to meet
people where they are day to day,
is what's truly exciting to me.
If you'd like to learn more about AI Companion, we've got a
QR code, but it is so exciting to work together,
and I look forward to the more we can do.
Thank you, thank you, thank you, Brandon,
thank you, Brandon to walk us through.
Through the applications,
Zoom applications,
and its integration, not only with
just index data, but with actions and
how they have enhanced their application with
QuickSuite.
Now I will change the gear.
We just looked into a use case
that is a business application use case.
It's a productivity improvement use
case, and now we will look into a different
kind of use case, and that is
around the security and identity.
And for that we have Bivutti
from Savient to talk about
their application and how they
have integrated with Amazon Quick Suite.
Thank you. Thank you, Sonali.
Brendan, thank you so much. It was really, really cool
to see what uh you guys are doing at Zoom, and
I'm very sure that we're going to start taking a lot of
advantage of uh those use cases.
But, but
now let's change gears as Sona you rightly mentioned. Let's
take a look at.
What are we doing with Amazon Quick
Suite when it comes to securing identities, which is a
serious business when you think about
putting compliance, putting audit hats,
and before I start talking about QuickSuite,
let me just
give you a very quick spiel of what has happened
in identity security.
If you rewind your clocks and go till
2014, 2015, what
you would find is that.
Identity security and governance was a mere
compliance plate. It was an audit plate. It was
thought of as a checkbox.
Are you certifying your access? Are you looking
at who is doing what with their
access, whether it was for human identities
or little bit of non-human identities
in that case.
But as 2015-2016
happened, there was a series of breaches
which happened and they used identity
as a launch pad
and what that changed in the identity
world was that identity
security
became more of a security pillar.
It became the cornerstone of any
company's cyber security strategy
that truly changed the narrative of how identity
security started evolving.
And then fast forward, when you started looking
at when uh generative
AI started picking up.
The biggest shift which is happening
now in identities,
this is now becoming a core pillar of
any company's business transformation.
If you are dealing with AI, if you have
an AI strategy which every
organization on this planet is doing,
you cannot have that strategy without
having a comprehensive identity security strategy
to have
a meaningful return on your investment with
what you're doing with AI you have to have
an effective identity security strategy
that's the major shift that's what.
Uh, happened and the reason why this all
happened was the definition of identities
kept on changing,
as I mentioned,
to 2014, 2015, every
organization on this planet was thinking about humans.
As an identity,
but the definition of those humans also
changed.
Uh, many of you would have noticed that during COVID
times there was a, there was a massive
increase in supply chain, uh, workers,
and that became a big notion of
the, the definition of identities kept on
changing and shifting from internal
employees to external workers.
Privileged users was always in the mix,
but then the ratio and the,
the whole rise of cloud
really changed the dynamics with a massive
explosion
of non-human identities
which started, if I remember it correctly, in 2017,
it used to be 1 to 4.
Today it sits somewhere between 1 to 60
to 1 is to 85.
That's the ratio with which the identities
have exploded.
And now with all
the work what the industry is doing on generative
AI, AI agents are the new norm.
The trend what we are seeing is that every
organization who have been in this
experimentation phase they're now
really putting these agents to work in production
environments and this is getting more and more serious
so that's what the evolution of identity
was and so far it has been going
on and that is why we
have been investing in Savient.
We truly believe that this is a single
most versatile unified platform.
To secure and govern any and every identity
which you have
for for enterprises, for organizations
who are looking
to secure and govern their identity ecosystem.
Now let's take a look at some of the deterrents
of when a company
starts building their identity security strategy
or the ones who are already having it,
where are the common pitfalls and how
our work with Amazon
has been really
a game changing thing in this, and I'll give you a
very quick story.
I, I started my reinvent in
2012 and that was the
year when.
Identity platforms were predominantly
run or used to run on-premise environments.
Less than 3% of identity
projects worldwide were successful.
Like, let that number sink in less than 3%
of identity projects used to succeed
worldwide, and the reason being was
upgrading an identity platform used to take
months.
But our partnership, I still remember spending my
first EC2 instance on Amazon. It was a very
proud moment
for us,
uh, taking our, our entire solution, deploying
it on Amazon, and then
the customers started realizing the benefit.
You won't, you won't believe when I say that
today. It takes a few hours
to completely patch, upgrade,
and go from one version to another.
In 2010, this was unheard of.
This was practically impossible to do it.
So,
let's again talk about some of the deterrents here. If
you walk into a CISO's room, the first thing
they would be worried about is
how am I going to be prepared for my audits.
Every CISO
they worry about two things. One, I'm going
to fail my audit because I don't know what
I don't know.
And second is the amount of time
it takes to prepare for audits is
insanely, insanely large. The reason being
is your data is absolutely fragmented.
Your data is very siloed.
Second one is
even today identity security is
done in a way that it is often thought of
like shooting in the dark. There's a lot of guesswork
in this.
There's a lot of reactiveness to it,
and the reason again being is that
if you think about identity data
quality or data hygiene, it's the poorest
in any organization.
It has come to a state where organizations.
Have accepted the the status quo
thinking that
the quality of your data is never going to
improve and that's again where we are
partnering a lot with Amazon their machine
learning and their generative a
uh large language models
to help improve the data hygiene and the data
quality. And then the last
one, which is the most important one, is
Integration with QuickSuite, integration
with Amazon Q, and many other technologies
allows us to bridge the gap, allows us
to remove this fragmentation.
In fact,
today, if you think about every enterprise, they
have something around network
security. They have,
uh, third party products for securing
their endpoints,
but the only context
which connects what is happening across
your entire ecosystem is identity.
And that has been missing in many, many
organizations, which is why the
whole ecosystem of bridging this
gap where systems can share data
easily
becomes a very predominant player, and that's what we are working
on. So as you start
thinking about
uh these deterrents and you start thinking
about how you can craft an effective strategy
what's very important and I'm very very excited
about is the work what we are doing with QuickSuite
so if you take a look at what we are doing
on the very top
are your crown jewels, the, the most
critical, the most important applications
or platforms
and. Amazon Quick Suite,
to Sonali's point, they're already ingesting
data. They're already ingesting
ACLs, permissions, all of that information
from here. And the consumers
of identity platform,
they can interact with Savient because they
don't have to deal with having these point integrations.
Savient ingests all this data
from QuickSuite.
They apply identity orchestrations.
They apply identity context to it,
and then that basically allows a customer
to have a frictionless experience
when they are thinking about consuming and
interacting with an identity platform.
And needless to say, uh, the
benefits what we are seeing, and I'll give you some numbers
here. The first one is all about,
uh, certification or access
reviews.
If you are not aware of what
an access review is,
think about it in this way that
especially in publicly trading com traded
companies or heavily regulated companies,
what your employees are having access
to or what your non-human identities
have access to
every line item has to be certified.
Now, multiply this
for an organization which has, let's say 55,000
employees. It's very common.
The amount of line items for
anybody to certify goes in the millions.
Which means that organizations spend
a lot of money, often millions
of dollars, to go through these access
reviews. Now
the thing what has happened over the course of the
period is we started seeing, and it's
a trend, it's a word used in identity
world very often, it's called rubber stamping.
If I'm going to give you 1700
line items to review that these are your
people who reporting to you,
go and certify their access, what's the best thing
you will do? You will select all, you will say this is
all good.
Let's go and
get this done with.
In publicly traded companies what happens
is
if there is something wrong it can be flagged
as a material finding which goes into your earnings
report that's the impact of
doing these things incorrectly.
So again,
where I was going with this is if you see
some of the the
cost savings both in terms of effort, both
in terms of the amount of money
you will spend in audit findings, etc.
it is, it is absolutely massive.
And that is why we are so positive, so
bullish about
these integrations.
Now let's talk or take a look at
all the things what I have spoken about. How does this
all things come into fruition?
How does this all things look practically?
And this is again fresh coming out of our
the work what we have been doing with Quick.
The first use case which I'm showing you here
is all about audit preparedness. Uh,
it's about
starting with an assessment of your entire platform
and then building what is going
to happen and where are the pitfalls.
The part which you will find here is that building
these assessment reports is not easy.
Usually organizations spend a lot of
money, a lot of time in hiring external
SMEs
who are going to collect this data from multiple
different systems,
and then they start building where exactly and
what exactly
the strategy
of your audit preparedness should look like.
The important part here is that when you start looking
at the integration with QuickSuite,
Quick allows us to ingest this
data from multiple different sources.
You can start talking to this data through our
MCP or model context
protocol interface
and rather than a human
trying to connect the dots by building
several different reports
trying to figure out where the blind spots are.
It all starts getting coming together in
one single way through a conversational
experience.
That's the power of this integration, number
one. Number 2 is
if you start looking at some of the action
items, how do you orchestrate, who do you
assign, what to do, it all starts
coming together, and I will show you another
aspect of how can we use flows
using this.
I'll give you another example. Let's say you are on
vacation
and after your vacation you come back,
let's say 10 days, 15 days, there's a bunch
of requests pending in.
One thing which every organization and every
consumer of an identity platform absolutely
hate is requesting access
and approving access.
And let's say if you have 37 approvals
to be done. How
would you know which ones to approve first?
How, how would you know that if I do not approve
the 36th 1 today and rather
approve the first one, it's going to create
a security gap or it's going to create a compliance
issue? The interaction with
the integration with QuickSuite allows
us not only to craft a
strategy of which ones you should be looking
at first,
but it also gives you why it should be done
first
and that is again a really game changing
thing what we are looking at because
it really helps as a
smart assistant to you or you
as a decision maker
to figure out
if you have a bunch of things to do which ones should
you be doing first and why you should be doing
it first. This is a very different way of
thinking.
And understanding how identity platforms
behave and again we are absolutely, absolutely
proud of our work with what and how Amazon
has been partnering with us on this.
So this is all about assessment this is all
about
consuming the information, chalking out a strategy,
figuring out what to do, how to do.
Let's take a look at another one which is something
which is absolutely near and dear to me,
and it's about identity orchestration.
Identity orchestration is the most
complex management task in any
identity platform, and I'll give you an example. If
you think about
building an access request workflow.
One of the healthcare,
largest healthcare providers of
North America I have been working on, when you look
at their access workflow, it
doesn't fit on a 49 inch ultrawide
monitor. It is
absolutely
insane when you think about such
complex workflows
on how are you going to manage and
maintain it on a day to day basis.
And when we started looking at quick suite
flows capability,
what really jumped was that
I think there is a time, this is the
tipping point we have been waiting for where
we can really alleviate these
complex tasks and have an easy way
to manage these orchestration tasks. So let's take a
look at this.
Oops
So let's take a look at it. In this case,
what you would find is that we start
building an access request workflow.
But access requests workflow should be done in such
a way that any
Entitlement, any permission, any
application which I'm requesting for, and if
it's of a low risk,
it should not even come to me
and that's where the push towards autonomous
governance is going to look like.
So what we are showing you here is
very simple check for all the pending
requests what you have.
Look for the risk flags
look for any kind of risk which is
embedded into that request.
And then make an intelligent decision
whether it should be
requiring a human in the loop to come and
approve it
or it should be automatically approved it
and this is all done through natural
language experience. You do not have to create,
you do not have to manage an orchestrating
workflow
which again can have multiple failure points
and uh
it allows you.
To push the boundaries, take it forward
towards a human in the loop manual workflows
towards a completely autonomous system.
That's where the future is. That's where,
uh, where we are really, really bullish on and
just to give you some more stats on an average.
125 applications
exist in any enterprise.
The average number of requests which flows
into your system is 225,000
to 255,000 in a month.
That's what happens in
large enterprises
with such
autonomous integrations
risk-based approvals. What we're
expecting is a 90% reduction in all
these workflows which are going through. And
again, Quick plays a very important role. Their
flows is really, really promising.
And we are really bullish on how
this can completely change the paradigm
of how identity security and
governance is done,
especially in large enterprises.
So with that being said, we are again very
bullish. We are thankful to Amazon for their partnership.
This is just a start. We are just scratching the surface,
as they say. It's day one,
and we
absolutely are inviting a lot of our customers,
prospects, design partners to come
and build more onto this.
So I hope this was useful. Sonali, once again, thank
you very much.
Thank you, Babuti. Thank you so much.
Now that you looked into
how a application
focused on security
and how they have enhanced their application
with Amazon Quick Suite,
and if you want to know more
about Zoom as well as Savvient's
application, we have resources for you.
Please, uh, take a look
to go further deeper into the use
cases and how they have integrated
with Amazon Quick Suite.
There are additional use cases that
the SAS application can support with Amazon
Quick Suite.
For that,
we have additional resources for you
to go a little deeper into Amazon
Quick Suite.
It has the documentation as
well as if you want to play around, have
the hands-on workshop, we have the
resources for that as well.
And
not the least,
if you are an ISP partner
of us,
please reach out.
There is a form
in the QR code that you can
directly collaborate with us
in Amazon Quick Suite. Let's build something
innovative together and democratize
the workplace.
With that,
I want to thank you.
Thank you everyone for being here.